[Music]
on this monday night pakistan's
deepening flood disaster
monster monsoon submerging a third of
the country this is a humanitarian
disaster
of very of epic proportions the
difficult rescues roads becoming rivers
and pleas for aid
the long wait for government services
it's really great standing in line for
three hours an update on ottawa's
mission to clear the backlog
the survivor's flag and you can see
their hope for the future canada's new
tribute to residential school students
and their families
and now your garden variety discovery
the ancient skeleton unearthed in a
backyard
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with a deadly climate
catastrophe gripping pakistan a third of
the country is underwater and what the
government says is the worst flooding
the country has ever seen
more than a thousand people have been
killed since mid-june 33 million people
are affected many of them displaced and
just to put that in context for you
that's more than the populations of bc
alberta ontario and quebec combined
these before and after satellite images
show the destruction communities washed
away pakistan's climate minister says
districts are beginning to look like
they're part of the ocean and the
disaster is driven by climate change
pakistan has never seen an unbroken
cycle of monsoons quite like this
eight weeks of non-stop torrential rain
a national emergency has been evoked and
the extreme weather pattern in pakistan
is alarming it follows some of the
highest recorded temperatures across
southern asia and tonight canada has
announced it will provide 5 million
dollars in aid to pakistan nita garcia
reports on the unfolding climate
disaster humanitarian response and the
mission to save lives
a stranded family saved after climbing
onto a bed frame strapped onto a pulley
system just above the raging waters by
volunteers with one of the largest
rescue ngos in the country
most welcome most will come you can see
many many cases so
how they rescue people from some
dangerous
places sometimes they grab sometimes
they put it on the back
just one example of the resourcefulness
of rescue teams in nearly impossible
conditions
there is no
movement on the tracks of the road is
not totally closed
this video shows the moment a luxury
hotel in swamp valley comes crashing
down due to the floods
eight weeks of unrelenting torrential
downpours with rivers bursting in all
directions have left thousands without
shelter and food more than 3 thousand
kilometers of road washed away
pakistan's federal minister of climate
change calling the scenes both human
caused and apocalyptic in this interview
with sky news
right now pakistan third of pakistan is
under water and
33 million are affected please tell me
how that is not catastrophic that is the
size of a small country i don't have the
words how we can express our feelings
definitely
our nation is crying at the moment this
halifax-based canadian with families
still in pakistan is trying to raise
funds for the rescues and the eventual
rebuilt with experts blaming the
catastrophe on climate change pakistan's
foreign minister is hoping for help from
financial institutions like the
international monetary fund with an
estimated fallout of at least four
billion dollars to pakistan's economy
that was already in crisis
the fact that pakistan contributes
negligible amounts to the overall carbon
footprint but we do
we are devastated by climate disasters
such as these time and time again and we
have to adapt
within our limited resources in whatever
way we can to live to this live in this
new environment the imf board will
decide this week whether to release 1.2
billion dollars as part of the bailout
program pakistan entered in 2019.
meanwhile the united states agency for
international development telling global
news a disaster management specialist
has just touched down an islamabad to
assess the impact of the floods and
american assistance beyond the 100
thousand dollars committed so far
nitu garcia global news washington
the impacts of climate change are also
being felt in jackson mississippi which
is bracing for flooding tonight
record rainfall has prompted the state's
governor to declare a state of emergency
and jackson's mayor is telling locals to
get out now mississippi's biggest city
has been battered by days of excessive
rain it's caused the pearl river there
to swell to devastating levels the river
is expected to reach its flood peak
tonight 24 hours earlier than forecast
up to 150 homes are in the path of
destruction and like pakistan roads look
like rivers and residents are being told
not to underestimate the threat or
return home until officials say it's
safe to do so
it's not weather but backlogs have
caused lengthy delays at airports and
canceled flights as well as long waits
for passports back in june the federal
government launched a task force to find
ways to fix the problems multiple
government ministers said today the
situation is improving but still has
some way to go as ross lord reports that
assessment is being called into question
after a chaotic weekend at vancouver
international airport where a shortage
of security screeners led to multi-hour
lineups and countless missed flights
it's hardly an objective assessment but
the government's own task force admits
what most canadians already know basic
services like processing passports are
still falling short the majority of
applications are still received by mail
or dropped off at a regular service
canada center and only 40 percent of
those were issued within the 20-day
business standard
there is some positive news there are
also fewer passengers that are facing
flight cancellations with 98 of flights
being completed the same as pre-pandemic
levels in 2019 but on any given day
airports are still a source of
frustration at vancouver international
travel plans were disrupted on sunday
when travelers waited for hours just to
go through screening you might
communicate a little better and take
care of the senior citizens
it's really great standing in line for
three hours on top of continuing stress
over the pandemic ongoing delays are
giving rise to impatient suggestions a
new government someone who is actually
reliable
playing into the hands of the
conservatives and leadership
front-runner pierre poliev who also
blames the trudeau government unions
representing government workers say they
tried to warn a big surge in demand was
coming but the government says demand
simply increased much faster than
services could respond noting other
countries are having similar problems
the government says it has hired more
staff this summer opened new offices and
customized some services by no stretch
of the imagination out of the woods yet
the focus will continue to be on
canadians and the results they expect
and deserve from this
or any other government as the pursuit
of short-term fixes and long-term
solutions continues travelers are forced
to make personal sacrifices like
arriving at the airport six hours in
advance to wait in line honestly today
was really really bad the slow going
continues improvements at times
impossible to see ross lord global news
a strike by tugboat workers also causing
big delays in one of the country's
busiest ports the largest fleet of
tugboats serving the port of vancouver
and victoria now behind picket lines and
that's trapped cruise ships in port
including the celebrity eclipse carrying
more than 2 thousand passengers bound
for alaska its planned sunday departure
was delayed almost 24 hours the strike
expected to quickly have a domino effect
on the already challenged supply chain
slowing down ship movements and
impacting port operations
it was an aggressive and frightening
incident of harassment in grand prairie
alberta on friday deputy prime minister
christopher freeland was approached by a
man who hurled abuse and berated her and
her staff the whole incident was caught
on camera and since then politicians
from across the spectrum have condemned
the man's behavior but as our chief
political correspondent david aiken
reports incidents like this one have
become all too common for politicians of
all stripes and at all levels of
government
deputy prime minister christopher
freeland had just arrived for a meeting
with the mayor christian yes what are
you doing in alberta
your traders
you don't belong here aides and city
hall staff defuse the situation and no
one was hurt but the perpetrator a man
named elliot mcdavid had clearly planned
the confrontation oh my god we came at
the perfect time that was perfect timing
video taken by mcdavid's accomplice
shows their excitement they believe she
walked in just like that
there are now some security reviews as
to how mcdavid did indeed walk in just
like that while politicians from all
parties and all levels of government
denounced mcdavid's actions the
confrontation at city hall captured on
video does not reflect the welcoming
spirit our region is known for alberta
premier jason kenney said the harassment
was quote reprehensible while the prime
minister said such threats have no place
in canada we need to call this out and
take a united stands against it the
frontrunner in the conservative
leadership race also said such abuse has
to end well it's
absolutely unacceptable and said his
family has received abuse and threats my
wife has received so much horrific
material directly to her social media
account that we've had to hire a private
security firm
to protect our family against all of
that abuse so unfortunately this is all
too common freelance cabinet colleague
marcy ian a former tv journalist said
women and women of color especially see
an inordinate amount of threats and
abuse abuse that was once exclusively
online but that is now very much in the
real world what happened to
the deputy prime minister
was reprehensible but not surprising
agree with with
you know my colleagues who say we have
to take the temperature down
but i will say that the temperature has
been decidedly high
for people of color
for racialized people indigenous people
in this country now if real world
threats are sparked by online content
well the trudeau liberals promised to do
something about that they promised that
they would introduce a bill within a
hundred days of being reelected well the
election was
343 days ago and there is no sign yet of
any legislation being tabled to combat
harmful online content farah
david aiken in ottawa thank you david
it has been more than six months since
russia invaded ukraine coming up what
could determine where the war goes from
here plus baseball legend mickey mantle
hits a home run from beyond the grave
ukraine's military says it's
long-awaited counter-offensive in the
country's south has now begun the goal
is to recapture the key city of kursan
and the surrounding region which was
occupied by russian forces back in march
at the same time an international team
of inspectors is now on the way to
europe's largest nuclear plant which had
been repeatedly hit by rocket and
artillery strikes redmond shannon has
the latest
handing out iodine tablets in the city
of zaparisia offering some protection in
the event of a radiation leak from
europe's largest nuclear power plant 55
kilometers away
a team of international atomic energy
agency inspectors has now arrived in
ukraine on route to the nuclear site
occupied by russian soldiers since march
this is an extremely unusual event i
don't think there's been anything quite
like it in history nuclear engineer
robert kelly led similar inspection
missions in iraq in the 1990s we were in
a position to go in with
the might of the coalition behind us
in this case they're going in as guests
i believe of the russians maybe the
russians and ukrainians
and i think that they might very well be
prohibited from doing everything that
they want to do
both sides in the war are accusing the
other of shelling the plant new
independent satellite images appear to
show a hole in the roof of a building
perilously close to a reactor 100 meters
away russia publishing these photos
blaming ukraine experts say the risk of
any meltdown event is low and limited to
about 40 kilometers around the plant but
nearby concerns still remain high the
nuclear inspection mission to zaparisia
begins as ukraine announces the start of
its long-awaited counter-offensive in
the south including in the neighboring
kirsan region after months of near
stalemate analysts believe this push
using weapons from the west could
determine where the war goes next
if ukraine is able to liberate hassan
that will be very important to the
overall war effort if russia is able to
hold on to the city in the region it
could act as a gateway for a future
russian offensive to try to take the key
city of odessa which could effectively
cut ukraine off from the black sea
meanwhile the british ministry of
defense says vladimir putin is now
bypassing his minister of defense sergey
shoigu and dealing directly with
commanders if true a further sign
russia's invasion is not going to plan
redmond shannon global news london
but that is under a curfew after
supporters of a powerful cleric storm
the city's green zone and government
palace
that after muktada al-sadr announced he
was quitting politics frustrated with a
stalemate over forming a new government
at least two people have been killed in
the violence with dozens of others hurt
sutter was the biggest winner in
october's election in iraq but withdrew
all his lawmakers from parliament in
june after failing to form a government
that excluded his rivals
houston we have a problem ahead why
nasa's road back to the moon has hit a
huge speed bump
a bit of a letdown for hundreds of
thousands of stargazers who either woke
up early or camped out to watch nasa's
artemis-1 rocket blasting off into space
the launch in florida was scrubbed after
multiple problems artemis 1 is an
unmanned mission to the moon and it's
supposed to be the first step for nasa's
return to the lunar surface
and is hoped to fuel a giant leap to
mars our mike armstrong was monitoring
the countdown this morning from the
canadian space agency in san fer quebec
the biggest rocket ever built was on the
launch pad and ready to go it had also
drawn hundreds of thousands of
spectators out in the early hours to
watch the show well the first issue was
weather the launch countdown was delayed
then came this announcement launch
director charlie blackwell thompson has
called a scrub
for today
nasa engineers ran out of time in the
launch window engineers were nervous at
first over a hydrogen spike in a fuel
tank that issue they determined wouldn't
be a problem but then they hit others
one of the four engines in the bottom of
the core stage of the rocket wasn't
cooling properly and there was an issue
with a vent valve on an inner tank the
head of nasa says the artemis rocket is
too complex to take chances
you don't want to light the candle
until it's ready to go
now there was some disappointment in the
crowds that gathered in florida and at
the canadian space agency in quebec but
this scrubbed launch will still give
engineers information that they could
only get by fueling up and almost
launching this is good data getting this
far in the launch sequence allows them
to test the system
this first artemis launch is a test
itself it won't have astronauts on board
but will make the trip all the way to
the moon about 450 000 kilometers
every part of the mission will be
analyzed and artemis ii will carry
humans in fact it's supposed to carry a
canadian astronaut that crew hasn't been
selected yet artemis iii planned for
2025 will be the first that sees
astronauts again actually land on the
lunar surface but to get to that stage
they have to get artemis one to the moon
we're learning all along the way we're
trying to do something that hasn't been
done in over 50 years
the next launch window for artemis one
is friday nasa engineers will meet
tuesday afternoon to decide whether to
go later in the week or give themselves
more time mike armstrong global news st
hubert quebec
let's leave the future aside and go back
many millions of years researchers in
portugal have released new images of one
of europe's largest prehistoric finds
and it's all thanks to some garden work
these gigantic bones belong to a
brachiosaurus a huge herbivore that
walked the earth around 100 million
years ago it's estimated to have been 25
meters long and would have looked like
this
this is the largest dinosaur fossil ever
discovered in europe and it was
originally found in a backyard in 2017.
get this while a man was working on his
house paleontologists have been
carefully unearthing it ever since and
they're still working to uncover the
rest of the skeleton
another relic has also left a massive
footprint in cash that is a rare
baseball card has just smashed the
record for the most valuable card ever
this 1952 trading card of major league
baseball hall of famer mickey mantle
graded near perfect condition was
auctioned off to a jaw-dropping 12.6
million dollars u.s on sunday the card
last changed hands in 1991 when it was
sold for 50 000
it also marks the highest price ever
paid for any sports collectible
a poignant reminder over the nation's
capital
next ottawa's new tribute to residential
school survivors
in ottawa today indigenous culture and
this country's shameful efforts to
eradicate it were in focus as a new
symbol was raised over the capital the
survivor's flag is dedicated to the
countless indigenous people who endured
the agony of residential schools and
it's going to fly over parliament hill
for the next two years before being
moved to a permanent home karen
lieberman has more
a symbol of a history once rooted in
shame now rising above parliament hill
it's a reminder that the survivors in
this country
are not to be forgotten the prime
minister joining indigenous canadians
from across the country to raise the
survivor's flag honoring those who were
forced into canada's residential school
system take an opportunity to meet us
know who we are don't just talk about us
don't own us as our survivors the orange
and white flag was designed by the
national center for truth and
reconciliation each element like the
children taken from their families and
the eagle feather all symbolically
significant and carefully selected in
consultation with survivors
you can see that the strength and the
commitment in the flag itself
and you can see their hope for the
future
the hope that the seeds that rest
beneath the soil will someday sprout and
bloom again as prophesied by our people
it says that we acknowledge
the intergenerational
trauma these
so-called schools
have caused
and that we
commit to continue working together
towards a future of healing
and partnership
last month a long-awaited public apology
on canadian soil by pope francis
sorry for the ways in which regrettably
for the church's role in
government-funded schools meant to
destroy indigenous culture and language
saint hen's residential school survivor
evelyn corkmas met with the pope and
previously traveled to rome and i
presented him with an empty box and i
asked him this is where i want you to
put the residential school documents
more than the symbolic gesture of a flag
cork mask wants all documents related to
residential schools released
it opens the true history of canada not
the ones that we were taught in school
but the true history the real history
and for me that's the only way
that
survivors across canada can find peace a
reminder of the resilience it took to
survive the residential school system
for all in canada's capital to see karen
lieberman global news
and that crucial reminder is what we
leave you with tonight in ottawa with
the survivor's flag flying over
parliament hill
that's global national for this monday
night thanks for spending part of your
evening with us
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
foreign